hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast i am
here with jeremy lee quinn
and before i bring him on and he says
thanks for having me i have a bone to
pick with him he has been on the podcast
before many of you will have seen the
episode he
did on antifa and the anarchist movement
and protests
largely here on the west coast but
across the country
he is now in washington dc actually i
believe he's in virginia but has been in
washington dc and was there
on the day of the riots that breached
the capitol
building and jeremy i just have to ask
you what
the hell you're reporting on antifa and
anarchism
one day and then the q anon fringe on
the right on a different day don't you
know you're supposed to stay in your
lane what the hell is this is it
journalism or something well yeah
brett it uh amazingly enough
these stories are connected and they are
intertwined in a very profound way when
it comes to even
the mainstream culture of right and left
in the united states right now that in
some sense aligns itself or gives cover
to these actions i would say
because these are populist movements i
would
i would characterize a lot of people
have been asking me who was there
i was there at the capitol i went all
the way up burrowed my way through the
crowd
and i'll talk about what that was like
because it was it was
like being at a music festival where
you're trying to get to the stage but
you're
a whole football field and a half back
and you have to burrow
through people and you just come to to
blockade after blockade
that's how it was an arena-sized crowd
i went prepared i thought black lives
matter plaza was going to be the scene
of the action so i was caught so
flat-footed
that i i rode up late probably 40
something minutes plus
into it and left my gas mask
in the rental car so i was flat-footed
to say the least um i i thought it's
just going to be the
afternoon protests the maga protests in
the afternoon from what we've seen at
freedom plaza both in december
and november uh were not my beat
because they were not riotous or are
conflict
bound i thought that black lives matter
plaza would be the scene of the clash
but the night before
on june uh sorry january the 5th
there was no little to no antifa
aligned activist groups that showed up
at blm plaza it was
just magga uh
who who actually went up against the
police line that was
keeping them from only like three or
four people at uh
black lives matter plaza now uh i
thought that was the story that i was
going to be covering
and continuing with which was uh
these anarcho-activist groups clashing
with the proud boys
of course because the proud boys
chairman gets arrested
right as he steps into dc that's a whole
other thing
i did not know when that i would be in
the capital
myself uh that day and i had that moment
for everybody
who's thinking what you went in i had
that moment as i was thinking what
happens
do i go in as a journalist and i
quickly reviewed my uh my um
thoughts on the on the uh free of the
freedom of the press and
uh the first amendment so i
when i got there i was not in the first
breach
i will detail that later it was more
towards
the probably one of the last breaches
that i was documenting
at the capitol but as i said why
am i not staying in one lane these
tactics i've emphasized this since i
talked to the new
spoke to new york times these
insurrectionary tactics
these ideas so to speak are
uh very they can be shared
and they can be appropriated
and expropriated from one group or
political
radicalized political spectrum group to
the other
i would say and in fact they inevitably
will be
and in fact the uh the um
anarchists have appropriated and frankly
just learned these tactics from other
movements around the world not all of
them but many of them so there's this
process of innovation in which
um these challenges to power are
uh learning how to resist the
um the machinery and the strategies that
come back at them
it's it's natural and it's inevitable i
will say on the topic of your
wondering whether or not you should go
into the capital
as a journalist it seems to me that
obviously there are reasons to
be concerned for your own safety and not
to go in but as a journalist
we needed you there we need as many eyes
on the situation as we can get so it's
obviously a journalistically
uh not only defensible action
but clearly something that
a journalist who's willing to take the
risks should do
that said i think this leads to a very
interesting set of questions because i
hear
a great many people playing with the
idea of
terrorism in this case and
i always feel the hair on the back of my
neck
stand up when people loosely invoke that
term because they don't understand that
it is it has become legally special
and that a journalist who would
ordinarily be protected by the
constitution
might be endangered by provisions in
particular of the nda
ndaa 2012 which
chris hedges amongst others uh a
highly decorated journalist in his own
right compellingly argued in a federal
court put him in jeopardy for having
interviewed i believe members of al
qaeda and so
there's a question about whether a
loophole has been inserted into
the american legal structure that might
cause a journalist like yourself who is
due constitutional protections to be
jeopardized
if somebody decided that what they were
reporting was
inconvenience so in any case let me just
say
i i regard you as courageous for having
done it i see
there is no moral compromise in you
reporting on
a story that captivated the world it is
exactly what you should have done
and um in the unlikely event that
somebody decides to go after you
for it i would just say uh you have
my support well thank you you know i i
also thought to myself i've
comes this far tracing these tactics
because i was pursuing a story
that was around different ideologies but
how critical mass
gives cover for tactics that was my
first
paper that i wrote in june was called
under the cover of protests what was
going on what were we not seeing
what were we not getting from mainstream
media the ideologies of the subculture
that's the other thing i know a lot of
people have a
viking seared into their their their
mind
and i asked my dad i said i said what do
you think he said no i've seen him about
15 times
the the eccentrics that make the
headlines
that that are social media viral
material that that spread like wildfire
the cherry picking
all of this is is important because it
it needs to be parsed we need to know
how many people were there was it tens
of thousands
cnn wrote hundreds of trump supporters
and it was an arena it was tens of
thousands it was an arena
size that's the best you know we don't
have accurate
counts uh come out yet i've been
googling that uh
like mad but it was an arena-sized crowd
and i i used that music festival
an analogy of just having to burrow your
way
over the course of you know 45 minutes
or so just to get
up to the capitol and then you have
these layers
at the capitol you don't just walk up
the steps and go in you
you had these terraces that were above
that could not
you could not get into them because they
were
uh interior stairwells that were shut
in the police so once they breached the
police
blockade once they they breach that
again with critical mass
just like the third precinct i would say
and people are i
i know people are going to say you can't
compare the two from whatever their
moral
leanings and political interpretations
are i will say this
i denounce i denounce violence
i am a pacifist at heart i've said that
before on your podcast
so i will say that right right now if
you're if you're sharpening your
knives and getting ready to come out aft
after me
for what i'm about to report as far as
nonpartisan truth about what i witnessed
what i
who i talked to uh that that went
across the character spectrum of the
right now
if again i um
i would say that what i what i
saw were different types of protesters
but you had the critical mass
and somebody texted me and a reporter
calling nick and
she kept texting me who was there who
was there and
my maga i mean obviously it was
connected directly to the president of
the united states
and i have said that he he bears full
responsibility
for what happened because the speech
this was one continuous motion from the
speech at the ellipse near the white
house
the march of the tens of thousands the
populist march
came right was scheduled as the wild
protest
and wildprotest.com was
up until it wasn't anymore so what is
wildprotest.com
wild wildprotest.com was an information
site which i didn't get to see because i
didn't click on it
in time before it was taken down but a
conservative contact
sent me a full uh list of the events
that were
happening the night uh before uh
blm plaza you know and there were
certain websites that were listed
from organizing bodies wildprotest.com
if somebody is good at finding
websites through google cash they would
be very interesting to look at it but it
was a populist website
that was promoting what the president of
the united states
himself termed was going to be a wild
protest
they ran with it whether people knew
how much people knew or didn't know is
very
similar to the protests that we have
seen all year long
they were autonomous in nature in the
sense that you had all these
different not everybody was paramilitary
and some of those guys i mentioned the
viking i would say were even
performative
right right i must say there's something
about the focus on the viking
i think people have the sense there's
something very
wrong with that and therefore we're just
going to you know
broadcast images of it but i'm
i'm not more disturbed by by the viking
in fact the viking in some sense seems
to me
like you know and i've i've seen some
things on your twitter feed and
elsewhere
where he's interviewed in other contexts
and while
i think his understanding of what's
going on in the world is incorrect
you know i understand where he thinks he
is so i i don't see him as sort of the
you know the high water mark of evil i
see him as an interesting measure
of just how divergent the mindsets
have become but before we get there
you say you and you you acknowledge you
don't know how many people were there i
feel certain
the federal government must have a near
exact count because
surely those plazas are amongst the most
monitored places
on earth and probably
that count was generated automatically
by systems that just simply can detect
the fact of humans as individuals but
what i don't want to gloss over is the
people who breached the capital
were a small number of people benefiting
from
i've forgotten your phrase but basically
the fact that the crowd
changes the game theory such that a
small number of people can do things
they couldn't
do under ordinary circumstances right
you have cover
you have covered from thousands of
people yeah recover which is exactly the
same thing that i have argued creates
uh looting which is that a system that
is built to prevent theft on an ordinary
day is overwhelmed by
natural or artificial events and at the
point people realize that that system
has been momentarily suspended
they do things they wouldn't other
otherwise do but nonetheless cover
exists but
the let's say it's thousands to tens of
thousands of people who are present
supporters of the president those people
were not in on nor were they necessarily
even aware
of the breach of the capital my
understanding is many of them
were far enough away that they learned
about it later is that accurate or
i would say that it was the rhetorical
pattern the the rhetorical message
was to to essentially lay siege to the
capitol
in other words the first people that i
interviewed i went up i was
that's the other thing i was trying to
say is you couldn't get up so you had to
go up scaffolding or you had to scale
the wall itself which we've seen many
images of people doing so i was going up
this rickety scaffolding
people were climbing spider manning
their way up in the interior of the
scaffolding so it was this elaborate
elaborate
um march to the rotunda
that that group that was out front that
was paramilitary and eccentrics like
viking viking or the
the guy from brooklyn with the pelts he
was like a jewish kid that
was you know uh you had these
performative eccentrics
that were in on the drama of it
but you had serious paramilitary folks
and i speak to one
in a live stream on my twitter which is
at j
lee quinn and i did a live with him uh
two nights later at in front of the
capitol and he called himself
pro coup he was even after that
he was still and i i wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait you gotta slow down there
because there are two mirror image
versions of the term uh coup circulating
in the same
story right so
my understanding is a great many of the
people
who stormed the capital yeah believed
they were preventing a coup
and you're talking about somebody who is
pro-coup right
so i'm trying to not only pro-coup he
identified himself as a right extremist
he said i'm an extremist
i said a fascist he said i like to say
federalist
and then he espoused some very um
uh i would say unpalatable views but he
was very honest about who he was
such as uh such as weimar germany
and uh national socialism and then you
start to go
down that cultural rabbit hole that is a
very
niche in my opinion of what you would
call racism
a neo-nazi and without without wearing
any without wearing any uh
affiliations i would say he satisfied
satisfies the requirement
that the leftist activists have been
looking for and
i have been looking for because i've
constantly said well the maga people as
a whole
i'm not finding that there may be
outliers well he was calling
and i asked him well how many of you
were there in your in your crew
in your and he kind of you know danced
around it it didn't seem like he had a
huge
crew but he was defining himself as
paramilitary
uh pro you know coup and as an extremist
uh dedicated to the president of the
united states so i did find one and i
did interview him cool yeah we will get
back to him
so at the very least in terms of our
uh gallery of different
perspectives that were present you have
a genuine
neo-nazi self-defined i would say i
would say yes
he says but yeah he says well i mean
national socialist right well he yeah
when he starts
talking about it in a positive light
then you start to say okay
we know where you're coming from i don't
think we need to split hairs
he's definitely in the neighborhood of a
neo-nazi yeah we've also got
a guy clearly carrying a confederate
flag
yeah in our capital right uh the report
said at least
one and i don't know what that means if
there were
at least yeah let's say we've got at
least one right that's a pretty
dramatic invocation of a very particular
thing
that the left frankly alleges is
commonplace and i don't think it's as
commonplace as the left says but there
it is in this
particular incident you also you also
have
uh what are we calling the guy with the
horns on his helmet
i'm calling him an eccentric and a
shaman
a primitivist of some sort he's uh he
has
an like this sort of um uh
paganist vibe to him yeah okay
primitivist
paganist i've heard him uh called
beowulf which i think frankly is not a
bad nickname
in this case but he isn't
i'm not defending him but he isn't like
those other two examples he is his
own outlier and less of an outlier
because what he says in
interviews that i've seen with him his
uh i went looking for his youtube
channel
which is suspended oh really um yep it's
gone
um so i wasn't you know and we will get
back to that because i think this
uh disappearing people's channels is
a part of the big story here and i'll
get back to why but
in his case what he says in the clips
that i've seen
he is convinced of the q anon
understanding of the
events of the recent past and he
is there defending i mean it's very much
i would say
um you know as a much more
standard view on
the alex jones right right he's
espousing a view
in which there are globalists that they
have targeted the u.s constitution
and he is there defending the nation and
that document right which is a very
different motivation than the
confederate flag guy
or the um the national socialist
uh federalists that you met and so
anyway my point
i think this will be obvious to people
who know me is not that i'm defending
any of these things
i don't think any of them are defensible
and none of them uh
justify the breach of the capital but
the point is you have
an eclectic mix of people who breached
the capital
you have a much larger group of people
who were present who provided what you
said was cover
who were responding to a message about
a wild protestation a wild protest
but here's what i think is
afoot here or at least partially
wild protest could mean something
symbolic
right wild protests and i don't know it
sounds like you've seen
at least recordings of what was on that
website i'm not even aware that the
website existed
this is the first time hearing of it but
you could have
a symbolic protest which many of us
would agree is a legitimate response to
concerns about the way the wheels of
government turn
and the fact is we can't hold people to
the standard of
only the accepted facts because the
problem is if it's only the accepted
facts then those who control
what is accepted control you know
obviously protest has to be able to
voice concern about things even if it's
not true
so the question is what
what is the interaction between a
president
who is i think clearly sympathetic with
people
who were involved in something that i
think is insurrection
right his encouragement
of a large
number of people to protest something in
a way that could have been
a simple symbolic speech it could have
been civil disobedience
it ended up involving a small number of
people
with cover or a small fraction of them
breaching
the capital but how are we to sort
between these things it's not
one group of people of one mindset it is
an eclectic mix of people who seem to
agree
on one thing loosely
right and it's it's populism and it's a
cultural populism
that binds it all together under
leadership
and this is i had a terse we'll get to
it later but i had a terse exchange with
a leftist
uh uh keyboard warrior type uh
journalist
activist journalist and we'll get into
how that plays into all this
and one of the the i point out that the
tactics
between the leftists you know were
appropriated but also
they had leadership and they had the
president of the united states uniting
them in leadership
to follow their emotional through line
to wherever it was going to to lead in
this
this spirit of insurrection the things i
heard
said the comments of course where 1776
will commence again
i've been seeing that all summer long in
response to covid restrictions and what
is defined as government
uh overreach and i've ridiculed it you
know i would
go i would argue with friends of mine
who are on the right
about this because i was very especially
the first
two months of covet i was uh i was very
keyboard warrior myself about all right
let's get in let's do this
um come on california where i'm from um
no wait wait wait wait what what was
your perspective for the time
at the time when we did not know what it
was
my perspective was all right let's bond
together as a
as a nation let's not make this
political let's get inside let's do the
let's do the things we need to do
and then you know so wait you were you
were a covered
hawk you were not i was a kind of hawk
and i even remember
publishing a video of santa monica when
people were still
uh you know on the trails and biking and
saying what the heck is going on
why aren't we getting it now things
changed a month and a half later
when i actually said okay they're
presenting research that the
transmissibility of this
outdoors is is not uh they don't have
the evidence for this and and they're
in fact it's being pointed to the
contrary shouldn't we be
at least opening the beaches and being
out and i got
just mauled by
really good friends of mine you know so
so you and i you and
unfortunately we have to do this
perfectly clearly because some people
what what you are reporting on is so um
interesting and the focus of so much
discussion that i think a lot of people
are going to see this who don't
know you or me and they need to
understand
where each of us are coming from in this
case i was and i would still say
i am a covid hawk i am also alarmed at
the way covet is being
used and the way we are having a an
absurd discussion
surrounding the costs of things like
lockdown closing public spaces outdoors
i have been alarmed from the beginning
about the fact
that outdoors and i'm not saying this
isn't changing
it could change evolution could change
this and it may be
involved in these new strains that
appear to be more transmissible we can
talk about that
another time but i am alarmed at
both the danger of kovid and the
response to kovid
so anyway i think you and i found
ourselves in the same
bind where an attempt to figure out what
was true
what was overreach resulted in an
allergic reaction
of people who were clearly treating this
in a partisan way
yes absolutely and i've known this i've
felt it and i've had
dialogue a friend of mine who i i've
known since kindergarten
uh who is on the opposite side of the
political spectrum
as i am because i as a left progressive
you know
here i am a former bernie voter and he's
libertarian right
and so he's very anti-mandated
vaccinations in
in in that culture and so he was
very hawkish on that side so i saw the
culture war playing out but one thing i
took away from it
was that people don't want to be
this group is against government
mandates government overreach and i
don't know how much that's being talked
about as people process
what they saw or what they think they
saw play out
at the capitol on january 6th but i
heard
a lot about the constitution i heard a
lot
about government overreach about 1776
and these citations all work together in
a
cultural an attitude of cultural
populism
now i'm looking in as an outside
observer i have a lot of contacts now
because i've made contacts with other
journalists
most of the i think i'm one of the only
from the cult
people from the cultural left who's out
there immersing
himself in both sides of this protest
and going
going back and forth and and uh um
so i i keyed into that people were
asking me well who
who was who was it who was it sure that
front line
had to be paramilitary they had to be
versed in tactics
the fellow that we talked about who
defined himself as federalists but were
were you know saying that you know there
are some neo-nazi leanings there and
uh uh he defines himself as an extremist
he said he studied tape he said you
don't know how many hours
of a video i've watched i studied antifa
and he calls them
antiphon and one thing you know when we
let we
we spoke last time i parsed what i say
i call antifa aligned groups that's the
terminology i
use because there is no one singular
antifa and part of the belief that there
is one singular antifa that has
communist leanings
that vacuum of information our inability
is the press to say exactly what's been
going on
since june and define that has left it
open for conspiracy i would argue
and so these cultures of conspiracy are
filling in the blanks with their
own information and i held i held a very
interesting
and i got every all three of us got heat
on new year's eve i did a live stream
with a black lives matter organizer from
utah
and a proud boys uh um
or leader uh from chapter leader from
utah as well
who befriended each other over the
summer and
started debating each other and they
struck up this friendship and they
realized
that they were fighting about all this
other stuff but they had several
comment points of commonality of
interest when it came to police reform
prison reform getting big money out of
the elections
dealing with housing you know they
agreed on all of these fronts and yet
they were fighting
about political identification and they
they came
forward right after the president
mentioned the proud boys well actually
was joe biden that mentioned it in the
debate and
the president uh notoriously said stand
by
stand back and stand by and and
during that um they came out a couple
days later
and there they got very little coverage
i think b-e-t
and maybe uh one right-wing uh
publication
wrote something about it but it didn't
get much play that they
realized oh my gosh we have all these
points of commonality that we actually
agree on stuff
we did this live stream and even the the
proud boy was saying
i'm nervous because there are people
there are people who have military
experience
that are pissed off that are that are
that feel disenfranchised
and i said well what did we expect
in the sense that if you don't call it
if you're the media
you don't call it objectively you don't
tell it like it is
since june wouldn't we think that other
people would take
these tactics once they're
disenfranchised
and it would all boomerang back on us
didn't we have the foresight to know
that if if
if if we didn't say anything and let
all these groups play out locally using
insurrectionary tactics and all the way
from i saw skateboard you know the
everything
that from the helmets to the gas masks
the skateboard to
to the pedestrian tools i personally
did not see one gun the whole time i was
there and that's significant
because the people on the front
apparently
from photos and it would be interesting
the to find out how many guns
were there but among the populist crowd
there were people with flak jackets body
armor but there weren't people with
with with arms that i saw so it would
have
have to have been a very small minority
but that all works under the same
that tactic of using these pedestrian i
saw a woman
with coming out with a um a chair
a leg to a desk like one of these ornate
swervy and it had been pulled off of a
desk and she was and she was
sorry uh holding it like a weapon and um
and so this idea of using makeshift
weaponry from
pedestrian materials that all comes from
the leftist movement what we saw
uh over the summer of insurrectionist
uh tactics from anarcho antifa aligned
groups
and i do get need to get to the
difference between anarchists and antifa
there's been a lot of talk out there the
antifa groups were not
a part of this because it's
ideologically
opposite of what they were saying black
lives matter dc said
everybody stay at home they said that at
the same time
some affinity groups um were
planning uh black black action but
presumably
at night at black at black lives matter
plaza they were preparing for another
repeat
of what i was expecting to cover which
uh was november the 14th
and december the 12th when those two
groups clashed at night and started just
larping and beating on each other so
yeah
go on so so those groups stayed up those
groups for all i know
stayed home they had a couple of
documenters that went
in to take pictures but from what we
could see they did not enter the capitol
they were culturally
just there as a fly on the wall the so
yeah
okay there are couple things going on
here and i have to apologize
to to my audience here
there are so many threads here that it
is very
hard to navigate this story and really
paint it in any disciplined way
and i regard that as a symptom of
the fact that there is a kind of there
is a force that tries to prevent you
from crossing the line it's one thing
to report on one side or the other but
it's a sin
to report on both it's a sin to try to
figure out
what the the middle ground is where
each side has it wrong what they might
have right
um and so the point is there are very
few people doing
what you're doing there are very few
people doing what i'm doing
the reason there are very few people is
that the pushback that you get
and the pushback even in terms of you
know
having your channels uh de-platformed
and things like this
makes it a very hard road to navigate so
what that means is that when
somebody like you who has seen both
sides of this
has been uh in the street has circulated
in
both settings that when you come to the
fore
there are just too many things to say i
have the sense that we could go for 24
hours and then really
exhaust all of the the threads that are
here so
yeah anyway i'm not sure exactly what to
do about that
but um yes the tactics
are deliberately
confusing they reside below a certain
threshold so that it is much harder to
tell the story so in portland for
example we had
um the antiva antifa blm
anarchists launching
uh fireworks at police officers
and federal buildings right fireworks
has a kind of a festive
connotation it sounds fun and dramatic
these are explosives are they explosives
designed to do a huge amount of damage
they are not are they dangerous yes if
you point them at somebody
so anyway the point is it's very hard to
report what happened you know
the fact that firearms were not
uh at least common amongst those who
stormed the capitals a fascinating fact
right these are almost certain to be
very well armed people
who left their weapons at home while
storming the capital
right yeah not sure exactly what that
says but it certainly says something
well that that yes there were not guns
everywhere
we've seen the pictures in michigan when
there were and and one
one note this this protest at the
capitol
salem oregon you have to see that that
was the uh
canary in the coal mine that you had for
the first time
right wing riots uh before christmas
uh at the oregon capital uh
those it almost when you look back at
that that video you think oh my gosh
that was just a small
tiny small scale idea
of what this sort of uh feeling was
coming from the right populist crowd
that was it you know you had the proud
boys did not show up if they were there
you wouldn't know and and uh their
chairman said we're gonna wear black
and he said that we all thought in
reference to
expected clashes with antifa aligned
activist groups
but no if they were there there were
lots of people that were all in black
and you couldn't tell
who was who and this is something that i
blogged the night of the
the fifth which is how will we know who
is who even on the night
or the night of the fifth when i was at
black lives matter plaza
an anti-covet restriction uh
anti-government overreach types were
you know yelling through the bull horn
and clashing with police trying to get
closer into black lives matter plaza
and there were some clashes uh i was
seeing
we saw proud boys who were in all black
and we also saw some people wearing the
orange beanies
of shut down dc which is the group that
famously showed up at uh was it josh
holly's residence
outside and with a megaphone and
so we saw some right rightists or people
on the right
wearing these people were appropriating
left wing accoutrements and costuming
okay so this takes me back to something
you said a few
minutes ago which i really want to
highlight yeah
the there is
the what you discovered where you have a
blm
activist and a proud boy discovering
that they have a great deal in
common but there are things they
disagree over but actually bonding over
the number of things that ought to unite
them
is i think the big hidden story here
that in some sense we are fiercely
divided
so that we will not be fiercely united
right and this is this is why i started
the
unity movement this is the exactly the
danger i saw coming out of this election
and the idea is there is a general
sense of frustration at
basically the public being frozen out of
the well-being that is generated by our
system
increasingly systematically frozen out
by
a pervasive culture of corruption much
of which is legal
and so the point is if you have a
legal culture of corruption that causes
the government
to do the bidding of those who can
pay to have their bidding done at the
expense of the public
it will create massive unrest
and distrust and the fact that that
unrest and distrust
is divided into factions that are
pointed at each other
rather than there being a broad
recognition that actually
yes americans have a right to be very
angry with what has
become of their governmental structure
and neither blue nor red is the solution
to it
blue and red are the problem and
how we americans address that is a very
difficult
puzzle increasingly this week i see
people
toying with ideas of the right scale
right
uh new political parties a recognition
that the parties that we have
are simply too compromised to be rescued
that seems to me
uh obvious right but people are now
discussing it
um and so in any case what i want to
point out
is that you're committing a kind of
physical heresy by moving between these
camps and listening to them both
because what you're going to find what
you are finding
what i'm finding by being someone from
what i would say
is the far left not the far left that's
in the street but
i come from a very left perspective and
i talk to all kinds of people on the
right who are not what i was led to
believe they would be
right yeah same so that discovery
is uh in some sense
the greatest threat to the narrative
engine that wants uh everybody to
stick to one version of events that
tells them
exactly who their enemy is and what
danger that enemy poses
and then turns off their processes of
reason so they can't discover
that's not even true right and this um
the events of the capital play right
into this
but you know in some sense you were
there you're you're the key to
understanding what actually
happened well i saw so many similarities
and
i tried to discuss it and of course
maybe it was
too early too soon because bringing this
stuff
up that that i was seeing the similar
tactics similar strain of populism
and one thing that i said as a riot is a
riot is a riot and it's just the same
stuff i'm seeing under different banners
and people just got furious with me
and i understand that i'm not talking
about
your the moral alliance to causes and
how you interpret them and
i'm talking about the people there what
they were talking about as far as the
constitution
and again it's defining the crowd they
define themselves
united under patriotism so while they
were trashing the capital they weren't
burning it
and there's some other significant
thing there's some significant images
that are being cherry-picked
again this was a five-hour ordeal
in which you had tens of thousands that
were marching in
and breaking police lines that were
completely unprepared for
this level of riot mass riot this was
this was just unlike anything i've ever
seen in my life
and once they'd breach one barrier
they'd breach another
and you know there were lulls where
where
where sure offered law enforcement gave
up
and just said threw up their hands and
you have a guy taking a selfie
and you have another image of people
just going through
but the problem becomes that we are
so quick to jump on a narrative an
activist narrative for our a tribalist
activist narrative that already the
story is being written
that makes its way to the
president-elect of the united states and
the vice president-elect
before anybody has even
spoken or asked a question to somebody
that was on the ground
now i'm not just talking about the
handful of of of reporters like myself
that that went all the way up and into
the capital and talked to people
and tried to get a beat on what was
culturally going on i'm i'm talking
about they didn't talk to
anybody and already you have you have
articles up from cnn before
people have even left there's articles
that are being written
about well if this was a blm protest
and and people are just going on this
they're not even
looking to ask the questions of who's
there
why were they there that's what
journalists should do and yes i am
committing this
uh heresy uh exactly because i get
attacked i don't i get attacked on both
sides for it
and uh it's interesting to me
that as i came down i went up once
and that was my scaffolding it took a
long time to get up to get all the way
up the scaffolding and then i was stuck
and i realized i couldn't get
across to the terrace and i was high up
and i
i'm one of the ones who climbed down the
interior of the scaffolding
and was you know monkey bars monkey bars
uh moving my way back down and it was
dangerous and at one point
a guy yells get out you know you know
and there were because there were dozens
of people doing this and then there were
dozens of people going up this
scaffolding staircase and then they were
trying to pour over
and then get up to the the upper terrace
and so there's a lot of the geo
geography of
how packed in we were into a small space
has a lot to do with the other three
deaths the we know about the shooting
death that happened in the two o'clock
hour but
the other deaths um there is a
right wing live streamer who i
have a uh i don't even know his name he
just goes by villain
at villain report on um he's from
your area and i've had some discussions
with him
and we exchange cultural notes because i
know a lot more coming from the left
than he does about what the left really
is and i tried to tell him that this
isn't one
you know united communist uh effort on
america
and you know and then he has he has um
information that
uh i that i tap into and i saw him
coming
out of what i would call the second
breach at around
four the four o'clock hour and he was
stunned because he saw a woman die
um and she it was not the one who was
shot but
um and names are swirling around in my
head so i'm not going to name um
the vic uh those who who passed but he
was there
and he said what happened was there was
there was mace
sprayed everywhere uh officers
people and people were getting crushed
up against the wall and he said people
couldn't breathe and she collapsed they
tried to resuscitate her
and he said he tried to get a pulse and
he couldn't and she passed right in
front of him and so when i saw him
coming out in the four
p.m hour he was he was dazed and
uh and he didn't make it all the way
in i went in later with a group that was
in one of the final breaches but so so
the the
um the confusion the was widespread
at one point i saw a canister when i was
on the very top level
being thrown from below to above
the canister was making it the gas
canister was making its way in the
opposite direction
so you had somebody picked up a canister
that had been launched by
police and returned it yeah possibly
i you know again this is
an even you know fireworks stuff was
coming in every
which way and it was again the identical
tactics the same
uh thing that i've been watching one
person said to me
i've been watching you know my my
website is publicreport.org
and that's where i host the unblocked
podcast where i try to talk to people
from
that are activists on the right and the
left and sometimes get them to have
actual conversations on the same
um cast and and um he said you know
watching all the clips that you've been
posting it's like i've been watching
this movie since
june and then all of a sudden at the end
of that
that film was this blockbuster ending in
which everything you
you know got turned up on itself and
it was it was stunning and people
thought
you know what were people saying when
when i went inside the capitol i was
approached by this scraggly sort of
duck dynasty bearded fellow who had an
american flag as a as a cape and he
walks up to me and he says are you
streaming
are you streaming and then i wondered
okay you know because if i was on the
left that would
be shut down you know i'd be shut down
because they oh they did attack the
mainstream
uh press pin and destroyed you know not
cameras over and stuff they're very anti
this group was very anti mainstream
media but i was just holding a phone
on a little you know stand and he says
are you streaming he's like come with me
if you want to see history and he was
very dead serious
and he leads me in through broken like a
broken
glass area to where a whole bunch of
them are just destroying furniture
and trying to make some kind of blockade
and i can go into detail that
uh of that later i can see you have a
question on well i do i
i want to highlight this issue there is
a kind of
um you know i unfortunately we don't
have
other versions but there's kind of a yin
yang
symmetry here where it's not the
identical same thing
in fact the relationship to the press
on the antifa left and the q
on right appears to be inverse and for
reasons that i think we can
we can understand which is the
press has proven the mainstream press
has proved compliant to
a phony narrative about the us being a
white supremacist place in which
you know uh blacks are fighting for
their lives in the street
every day right it just it's a narrative
that is provably
false it may be a stand-in for a
narrative that's true but much harder to
describe
but in any case the press is
the mainstream press is looking
for examples that
point in the direction of trump is the
problem
it's the republicans the solution is
blue biden is the answer
and so the antifa left has been
utilizing that and in fact they've been
effectively trying to
create incidents that the press can then
edit down to something and say aha
right the federal fascists came to
portland
and this you know uh ragtag band of
resistors fought them off right well
that's not what happened in portland but
if cnn reports it it becomes something
so the the antifa left is playing the
mainstream press
and the q and on right is allergic to
the mainstream press because
there there's nothing there for them
right so
anyway these two sides have an inverse
relationship and the destruction of
those cameras rather than
you know and the antifa left is of
course hostile to the individual who
wants to report the story on the ground
because that gets in the road of them
gaming the cnn msnbc
system right so and anyway that that
asymmetry is interesting
that's that's that's very um that's very
accurate i just want to
uh take from that that when you talk
about the narrative i think
i would rather push back a little and
say that they're exploiting
the um black lives matter uh
populist movement it's being exploited
by those who want to control the
narrative
and who have burrowed in as at keyboard
activists
and that keyboard activism and i'll get
to it in a minute
is was already happening one hour into
what this big five
hour event was it was already being
trying to
get people to think that that
this was just people that walked in like
a couple people like in michigan
with that just walked in and i wasn't
there so i don't even know how to
characterize that over you know back in
the spring
but but the idea that people just
waltzed in is patently false ridiculous
and contrary
to everything and people will see that
as more video comes out that's why the
video needs to be there
is that there were so many different
breaches there were so many obstacles
the the police were overpowered it's so
many
at one point a guy is climbing and
and either an officer or somebody knocks
him off and he falls
um you know a story and i don't know we
don't know if there's going to be more
fatalities in the future because uh what
was going
on was an all-out siege of the capital
and it was
it was it it was the critical mass in
other words
of the of the populace that was behind
it just like
just like minneapolis of course these
are different
i'm not weighing in politically on
what one group of people thinks in
another i'm just
saying that there are if you if you
don't want to look at some
similarities then maybe don't
don't listen to me here i guess well
right
so i mean at the very least i believe
there are now
five fatalities yes because an officer
another woman who was shot
a police officer died three people one
of whom
sounds like was overwhelmed maybe they
had medical
uh problems and they were overwhelmed by
tear gas
somebody else was crushed so
at the very least yeah yeah so i've been
wondering about those three other
fatalities um i find it very conspicuous
that they're
reported as uh people died
you know in medical emergencies well i
saw a man collapse
um towards the end of it uh towards 5
p.m
i saw a man just collapse and just fall
to the ground
and an older man and i don't know if it
was one of the uh
two male fatalities that uh
what that wasn't the officer because an
officer and a lot a law enforcement
officer also died
so so um i did see that i
we were so packed in at certain
corridors if you were trying to get
further
and by the end here's this was
very interesting by the end they were
just trying to get people out now i
i was in the last group that came out of
the capital there was gas everywhere we
were being gas were being ushered out
still some women were uh were who were
next to me
who were with um there were like
grandmothers for trump is a thing
one of the one group of the first groups
that i interviewed were part of
grandmothers for trump that were in the
first preach
and i live streamed with them and they
were hugging each other and they're
saying we did it we did it we showed
them that this is our house
so that was very explicit about what the
populist attitude was
from these moms from orange county at
one point a mom from orange or i don't
know if she was a mother but she was an
older
woman from orange county said i'm going
to latch on to you and she held on to me
as we burrowed through trying to
to get through so so um it toward the
end they were still resisting these two
elder women were still going against the
cops and we were being pushed out
i just kept saying yes i just kept
saying yes
yes and i was trying to just put that
energy because we were
you know crammed up against what would
be a fall if
these um railings are not uh
they're concrete barriers that are lower
than you know
your uh your torso and so i was just
saying yes and trying to get out
this is a very interesting thing as
people were leaving at the very end
i heard people shouting traitor
and oathbreaker to the to the officers
and it was mostly the virginia state
police that was called in the virginia
state police came in
around uh four o'clock and they did a
lot they were ushering out doing a lot
of the heavy work towards the end
didn't the didn't the virginia national
guard show up
uh i don't know ice the cars that i saw
all saw
all said virginia state police and very
clearly there was a massive virginia
state police presence
that was involved especially towards the
end of getting everybody out
some people were yelling oath breaker
and trader other people
said thank you to them so it was this
bizarre dichotomy
of people who are back the blue and
a pro law enforcement were saying thank
you for your service
and then other people were saying oath
breaker in trader
and that was going on
right next to each other without them
censoring the other in other words one
person then
did hey did you say oathbreaker it was
right
the idea was everybody gets to say what
they get
to say and in doing that
of course you're gonna cherry pick the
eccentrics um
there is a guy with an auschwitz uh
hoodie or something
and interestingly enough when this
happens similar similarly to
in december all of a sudden you they
start
sights start popping up where people are
trying to sell
it you know oh that explains it i went
looking i saw that
uh image of the guy with i don't know
camp auschwitz
which yeah a horrifying thing like that
uh and i
tried to figure out whether it was a
reference to something and i ended up
at some site selling t-shirts that had
nothing to do with anything
uh well i guess this is a tactic and you
don't know if it's from
from the um alt-right or the alt-left so
to speak
you don't know which of the extremists
are doing it
but this happened with the
shirt of the 6m the six
they they translate it to saying six
million wasn't enough that somebody who
was in the proud boys was wearing
a shirt that said six m uh
something e or or whatever it is uh once
people took that image and then it was
widespread
um all of these sites started popping up
faux sites that were selling the shirt
supposedly
all over the internet to make it look
like this was a widespread
thing well no in so this is different
i'm not saying that isn't the case i'm
sure it is
um the thing i ran into was a site
selling
shirts that had nothing to you couldn't
find a camp auschwitz
shirt there they were just selling what
seemed to be random
slogans so i think it was just somebody
parasitizing the fact that there were
suddenly a lot of searches on that
i see what you're saying um but you know
i that happens
that happens is you have these these
people who get these shirts
probably custom made and then somebody
an activist finds them it goes viral and
then all of a sudden you have sites
purportedly selling said shirt that are
then taken down
within 24 hours because they're not real
okay so yeah
there's one thing that's really
important here then so what what we are
discovering what i think both you and i
know from experience
but is very very clear in this incident
is that a tiny number of
um what i would call people
on the fringe of the fringe right actual
nazis who you said the last time you
were on my podcast
that you had not encountered these
people even though that you had been
told you've now encountered one so i've
now encountered one yes
you've now encountered one in the wild
okay yeah that that's an
outlier right a guy who would carry a
confederate
flag into the u.s constitution in 2021
i would say that's a different kind of
outlier maybe not as far
afield a guy who would don a
camp auschwitz t-shirt these are extreme
outliers who were
in this group but they were not
representative even of the extreme
fringe that i've already said was
involved in an insurrection
into the capital and that fringe who was
involved in the insurrection
into the capitol whatever their
reasoning was uh
left their guns at home at least for the
most part that's interesting
yeah and then you have this large number
of people outside the capital who
some have told me many were unaware of
the breaches maybe that's
not true i don't know what there was a
rumor mill when
when i was in the crowd you had a rumor
mill going
for example at one point someone said
that they got into pelosi's office there
was very intermittent
cell phone reception because you had so
many people it was that rock concert
thing
that you can't you can't access the
internet you couldn't stream
uh so sometimes people were getting
incorrect information about the woman
who was shot and killed but we did
that spread like wildfire when we heard
that a woman had been shot and killed
you know some people had the age wrong
and so forth but that
spread like telephone and that's how
information was being passed you really
couldn't parse
what was true and what wasn't but we did
know that somebody was
was shot and killed in the crowd and
uh even though you know remember that's
the 2 p.m in this
hour and this goes through the 5 p.m
hour uh
people kept going people weren't gonna
weren't gonna leave some
cleared out it was like okay we were
there
but uh you know maybe the crowd went
down to half but people were still
i don't know if that's accurate but
significantly people peeled off
um i had come down and i did a live
stream that's when i talked to the
grandmas
and for trump that were congratulating
and hugging each other
from knowing each other from the circuit
of going to these trump rallies
and then i went back up that's where the
scraggly beard guy
takes me up into the capitol and we're
in
offices we i didn't go to the rotunda
we're in some
offices which they have completely been
destroying all the furniture
and they're building some sort of
barricade and arming themselves with
table legs
and making a charge through this sort of
uh smaller corridor uh the guy with the
with the and again you get down to
performative eccentricity sometimes with
these
people up at the front the guy with the
scraggly beard and the
and the american flag as a cape starts
uh going for john fogarty clear credence
uh it ain't me it hit me he said
i ain't joe biden's son and then he
opened the door and led the charge um
down the corridor and they got into
these offices and just started
ransacking them
and trying to break out the windows and
one guy was trying to get the mac
um it was a big flat screen mac uh and
so forth
i'm sure he never got it out because we
got smoked out of that um
within you know uh ten minutes or so
so uh i'm also getting this weird you
know back to this sort of
sorry i just need to correct i said we
they i was there i was there
uh as a documenter uh
and i want to make that perfectly clear
because that's not something that i want
to uh
to yeah but for what it's worth it's
clear to me that this is confusing
because to the extent that you and other
human beings are
driven out of a room by smoke or tear
gas
uh there is a we and then to the extent
that you you were there reporting on
them
uh that's not a we right that's of them
so
anyway both of those things are live and
i think uh
you know my audience will understand the
distinction
but uh there's a there's something just
very
interesting you have in effect two
different kinds of anarchism i i've made
this argument for many years that
there's a kind of there's a thread that
links
the uh the anarchists and the
libertarians the extreme libertarians
right that they believe in some very
similar things but
they dress differently and in the case
of
antifa anarchist black bloc you have
this deindividuation
this attempt to blend in so you can't be
identified and they're obviously
tactical reasons the primary reason to
do that is tactical that you can't
be picked out of the crowd by by law
enforcement
but on the other side the queue and on
right side
you have the inverse you have a you know
a guy literally wearing a
viking helmet you know bare chested
right the guy's so identifiable that you
know inside of
hours of this happening everybody in the
west is aware of this person
so there's this sort of hyper
individuation there's no
discipline whatsoever what are a bunch
of grandmothers who think they're
defending the constitution
doing in an insurrection with a guy in a
camp auschwitz
t-shirt a confederate flag and somebody
who says he's
sympathetic with national socialism i
mean this doesn't
make any sense it's chaos it was chaos
and it was an
anarchistic in more than the just a
superficial way and i'll explain that
as well but but yeah the grandmothers
that were all
following the guy with the scraggly
beard as he as he you know
quoted john fogerty so he quoted john
fogerty yeah
you know presumably would want nothing
remotely to do with this
yeah yeah yeah joe biden's son and they
all went i mean it was
it was surreal to say the least and
you know the confederate flag which you
you mentioned
um if you want to call it an outlier
it's the most consistent one
because the social social justice left
or the progressive left of which i am
culturally from
sees it very different very different
than
um than other folks and and it's
it's a media divide on interpretation
and
uh we get you know we know to decry it
but uh even when i was in tulsa
the same performative thing a guy had a
kitty bike
and the kitty bike had a big long you
know bendable pole going out the back
with a small confederate flag on it
but the idea of freedom of speech
in other words i keep asking people
when people the material that you're
reading have people
mentioned anti-globalization have people
mentioned constitutional being
constitutionalists and
freedom from government overreach
because these folks characterize
themselves
against big tech also
i heard that a lot they were railing
against big tech and
big media and corporate media especially
as i said they trashed the equipment
at the media pen and
the idea that um
this portrayal of them and their
heritage
and this is going to start sounding like
an apologist and i'm not saying
anything as a value judgment on the
confederate flag i'm just
saying that they don't police hey dude
take that confederate flag down because
there is a commonality of um
of freedom of expression that is
so specific and uh
trumps all everything else because they
feel they're being policed as far as
their freedom of speech
all the way to history now to the
history of the country that they're
being
policed and they don't believe in that
form
of freedom of speech and then so you
would say to yourself
why isn't somebody smacking that guy
with a camp auschwitz
hoodie across the face and saying dude
get the hell out of here but that's
they maybe they i don't want to
rationalize i don't want to make a value
judgment
i'm just saying the current of the the
freedom of speech
i i will fight for their right to say it
even though i
don't agree with it that current is very
strong
in this libertarian-esque uh populist
maga uh group so okay
very good um couple things to say
one the right
fringe and i think the right fringe you
know
almost was geographically displayed
in the assault on the capital right you
had a large number of people
on the right fringe uh and then
that goes all the way up through these
um the fringe of the fringe who were
inside
wearing these uh offensive symbolic
t-shirts and
and everything else so that's not one
thing right
you've got grandmothers who were
committed enough to actually
you know engage in an insurrection
um presumably in favor of the
constitution and you've got every other
uh stripe they do a
terrible job of enforcing
any sort of um
there's nothing that rules out your
ability to join that group
right and that indicts them the fact
that you don't police the guy
in the camp auschwitz t-shirt is in fact
uh evidence that you're missing
something very important
the opposite thing happens over on the
antifa
left right where there is this
hyper discipline you cannot deviate from
this uh
the exact description right to say
that not all cops are bastards is to
declare yourself a fascist
right this is it's the opposite problem
and i will say i take a lot of crap
for um spending more time
talking about the hazard of
the extreme left than about the hazard
of the extreme
right now i think i'm in a better
position to talk
about the hazard on the extreme left
because the left is my home
and so i see it better it's a natural
and i also feel it is my obligation in
some sense
to um say hey look there's all this
stuff circulating on the left
that's extremely dangerous right i don't
want that to become synonymous with the
left
i want it to be understood that there's
a diversity of opinion
and that some of these people really
just simply are crazy the fact that
they're on the left
doesn't mean they're my responsibilities
so i want to i want to
highlight those distinctions but in any
case you've got
folks on the far right who are not
policing
their membership so that frankly nazis
can circulate amongst them
even if most of them would not have
sympathy with it enough that you would
have
not encountered such a person until this
very extreme
historical event um but
i will say things like the
distrust and antipathy for big tech
right this is a very interesting issue
the right thinks this is about
them it isn't big tech
is policing anything that challenges
their control
over the narrative i have been tossed
off of two platforms
in the last year one of them personally
facebook threw me off
and the other one the articles of unity
account which was the
official account of the unity movement
which i initiated
was thrown off of twitter and remained
suspended i was able to fight my way
back at facebook
but the articles of unity account which
was decidedly nonpartisan
started by somebody from the left was
thrown off so
in some sense the responsible folks on
the right need to understand that the
fact that they
face a kind of asymmetry when it comes
to big tech
isn't about right or left
it is about control and the fact that
big tech
happens to view it it's aligned with
team blue
is confusing them and they should they
should get over it
interesting i i hadn't thought of that i
mean a lot of my videos have been
either squashed or i tried to report i
did not the one city i didn't go to
through all this was kenosha
but i was in a position to grab all the
feeds and edit them together
and that video was going just going and
then all of a sudden
was squashed my ability it's also a pay
to play
sort of thing you you have to put money
in
to content to get it uh going
in facebook now here's something that i
pointed out to a friend i used to work
when i was living in new york city
i took time off from journalism and i
worked for a startup that got all this
google seed money and we were
launched trying to figure out how
material would be shared
and they had a comedy division i used to
work with comedians and be involved in
that scene so i was working with
comedians
and stand-ups producing content they had
fashion and then they had extreme sports
which i think was the only
uh success that they had of those uh the
the what they were looking for was how
does content work on social
what we are most concerned about is how
how can we create content
and it gets engagement and it's shared
and at that time they were hiring very
young you know millennials because the
millennials would understand how that
worked
what you found out was that people
i think i look back that was like six
years ago and how that's evolved
people what to answer that question what
are people sharing
they're sharing content that provokes
outrage
and consolidates this tribal outrage
that is that is similar and uh
um and you don't you don't
waver from that emotion of that
emotional response from that content
that's what they figured out in those up
until now is that content that goes
viral
is shared because of these tribal uh
outrages that that you are able to sort
of ride
from you know the algorithm and
that's what's profitable that's what's
making money
in in web content so it didn't surprise
me and i was preparing myself
when i was coming down from the capitol
and
i was thinking to myself how are people
going to interpret this because i've
been shut out from
with with no cell phone reception from
what's going on
on cnn and i thought to myself okay
they're anti-big tech they're anti-media
they're pro-constitution you know
anti-government outreach how do i try to
characterize
this maga patriot thing that's happening
because people keep asking me
who was there was it antifa no was it
anarchist well some people
can be anarchistic on the right
anarchism is a very flexible personal
philosophy and the leftist anarchist
just
just you know a lot of them can't take
that but the classical anarchists
kali lawson who was one of the
organizers of
occupy wall street who i interviewed for
my podcast said anarchism
is a free-for-all it's a it's a
fuck-all attitude of anarchist spirits
and he said the second you start
doing divisions those classical
anarchists the old school they
he said i think i told you this before
he said it makes me want to reach for my
revolver which is sort of this
revolutionary
sentiment but uh so the idea that
ana antifa is definitely a social
justice
left anti-fascist even
i for breaching the conversation and you
they would label us as the opposite of
anti-fascist and we know it
how that game plays out so that's a
very strict social authoritarian order
on the left
anarchism is different because it's much
more flexible
and it can be applied to the right and
that's why you have anarcho libertarians
that were militia in kenosha who said as
long as you don't [ __ ] with each other
and you [ __ ] with the government we're
with you
were the exact words and he said all
lives can't matter until black lives
matter so they were aligned
with a struggle but they were
libertarian
and then you had libertarian left like
the guy
his name was ivan hunter harrison and he
was charged for
shooting at the third precinct and
yelling
uh justice for george floyd and he was
aligned
from another guy from the carolinas who
got busted for trying to sell
this was all boogaloo stuff and the
boogaloo falls in that ambiguous
territory
because he was busted for trying to sell
arms to hamas
and then you have other boogaloo who are
trying to kidnap you know the governor
of michigan
and one of them has an anarchist flag
behind him so this hybrid
the way that the subcultures are
are are intermingle mingling way beyond
our understanding of right and left
goes very deep and this is just all a
result
of the internet because as much as i'm i
was focusing on shared content and
people making
money from that content that that
provokes a symmetrical outrage
you also have people who are
cross-pollinating in these
in these very fringe bizarre ways
well you also have what i have argued
is a essentially
literal group psychosis
that what we have is incoherent
incomplete thought patterns resulting in
behaviors
that make no sense except relative to
some internal
world right so you know
what is the correct reaction to a world
in which uh cops shoot
black people regularly and
get away with it scot-free because
that's just how things
are right the reaction to that world
would be one thing
it happens it's provably not the world
that we live in
right but if you are
trying to sort out the truth of what
world we do live
in and the channels that are supposed to
help you navigate
what world we do live in are compromised
then the
answer is you're sort of reading tea
leaves to figure out where you are and
then some video
shows up that suggests you live in that
world and the answer is well okay let's
go we all know we've been preparing for
this we know what to do
likewise you know what do you do you
know in a world
where you know the globalists have
uh you know targeted the constitution
and uh are this close to establishing a
new world order in which you're
uh you know going to be a
wage slave or worse for the rest of your
life and so the point is these are
wrong descriptions of the world but they
are
flowing into a vacuum where the thing
that is supposed to help us
make sense of the world and figure out
what world we actually do
live in has been compromised and
hijacked by various things some of them
utterly mundane economic forces
some of them systematic in their
attempts to gain power
and control and so anyway it leaves a
totally confused populace
in which basically everyone is left to
their own conclusions and when they
extrapolate from them we all express
horror at what some group of people is
doing because it doesn't make any sense
relative to the world we think we live
in
and we have to do something about that
the fact is we cannot just point at
others and say
they're acting psychotically because
they are acting psychotically but that
description
accounts for almost everyone and the
thing that is most necessary in order to
cure
the psychosis are people who are willing
to do what you're doing and what i think
i'm doing
which is to follow these stories where
they lead
process the evidence irrespective of you
know
who it reflects poorly on
and try to grapple with its implication
and of course the irony of ironies is
that for doing that
we're everybody's enemy which uh you
know i
people really need to recognize that
that whether you like what you're
hearing or not
that the obligation to protect anyone
who is at least
trying to do this uh dispassionately
and fairly right whether they do it well
or poorly just simply the attempt
is an indication of honor well i
and i found that there are some who are
willing to talk as i said i i
spoke and saw the blogger
villain report and we live streamed
together
afterwards and did a kind of debriefing
of what we saw
you know he challenged me on why i voted
for biden
i challenged him on other things but but
the dialogue was important because we
weren't seeing each other
as political adversaries we were trying
to process and he's someone in his
in his reporting of uh he live streams
and when when he comes on to his side
behaving bad
he addresses it he captured a very
graphic moment in december
on the 12th where the proud boys moved
unilaterally on an
end to the group now that that video
would later be
opportunistically cut to make it look
like the proud boys were
talk attacking some random couple which
wasn't the case it was a black block
antifa group and at the beginning he
says
oh my gosh this is antifa there and uh
what this is not good they're in the
wrong
area you had this they were coming
through or there's got this big maca
crowd
and ended very violently and
persistently violent
you know and this is where you get to
the madness of the mob
it is no one group no matter how moral
they think they are is immune to the
total madness that takes place
when adrenaline takes over and people
are fighting in the street and they just
are going as far as uh
as it will take them and your reason
is left at the doorstep i talked to one
conservative
who uh she's i would say controversial
in the sense that of
being one of these activists and even
she was like the next day i don't know
what i'm glad i wasn't there i don't
know what i would have done
because she's one of these people who is
operating on emotion
for what i think is a very misunderstood
representation
of black lives matter people who are
anti-black lives matter
we went over this and i received
pushback but from some viewers
i think black lives matter has been mia
i think it's been
uh uh the the uh the leadership uh
and all these other groups there there
has not been
enough differentiation that the press
has been willing to take on
and say okay these are what these antifa
groups are which we talked about
in 2017 if you're the washington post
and the daily beast you
ran articles about these antifa groups
and then you left it alone
since then and so uh the uh there hasn't
been enough
of distinguishing what anarchism is and
anarchist
tactics and insurrection is that we have
an understanding this is
not just a right left thing but there is
shared experience
and the least of which is the total
madness of the mobs
yes absolutely so for people uh
watching this who don't find themselves
in one of these groups or
the other which presumably is almost
everybody watching this
one thing to just track is
this is a measure of
a broad sense of
profound and dangerous dysfunction you
have lots of people
acting very aggressively attacking
structures that clearly are
essential to to the nation and therefore
to all of our well-being
across the political spectrum right that
is a measure of the dysfunction of the
thing that is supposed to be
protecting and guarding these people
right that shared understanding that
something has gone wrong
is it is a symptom but it is a symptom
of the thing that we have to address
right people are not going to allow
themselves to be
frozen out of the well-being that they
generate or
left to fall through a shredded safety
net
quietly so the particular way this is
manifesting
is interesting and perhaps unexpected
but the fact
that people are in this
mood so broadly is an indicator
that um you know the alarm is sounding
and this is what it sounds
like is what i would say yeah
and uh i saw a sign
in in december that said now
we revolt and we was capitalized it was
somebody on the right
that was holding it and it just because
that was of course after you know
biden's won the election and uh
and uh i just had this ominous feeling
going into the new year of when is it
gonna boomerang back
i did not know it would be so soon so
definitive
and on such a massive scale and one
the of the of the right
wingers that i that i uh interviewed
said
this is how he characterized it he said
these people some of them have
you know former military training and
they don't
they're upset they um the way that
you know folks like us are portrayed
constantly
uh across the boards the the fact that
uh
this stuff has gone on as long as it had
on the left without the media really
being honest with it
he said i'm very worried i'm very
worried this is before
you know the capital on january the 6th
he said i'm very worried about what what
is going to happen that's somebody who's
considered a moderate
and he was called a capitulator and so
forth we will not capitulate is sort of
the the talking point from the those on
the right
so i do want to address this
experience of being in the middle of all
this and
you can tell that i'm still hyped up on
it in the sense that i've
not only had was there to live
have the lived experience but then i
have to go and i have to research and
stay up all night looking at all the
stuff that i've missed and that that i
didn't see
that there were people we were on the
west side of the capitol there were
people who came in from the east side of
the capitol even
you know keeping track of the fatalities
and what what uh
the processes you know the new york
times wrote a piece in which they really
lay out
the different uh the timeline and and
the geography of it because people are
again i have to say this is a five-hour
event there were highs and lows of
course there were times where these
folks were
crash clashing with the cops and there
were times where
where i'm sure it would have been
you know just turn on the good cop thing
and try to just
and there were probably times of
submission where you have tens of
thousands of people who have breached
the capital of the united states of
america are you going to
you know after people have died one
a woman is shot another woman we know uh
it was you know suffocated in trample
and then two others died possibly heart
attack and
other other causes so so you know people
are dying
at what point is that photo that you
take to make your
your social justice point where does
that lie in that five hour timeline
right that's significant and this is the
other thing that
that you know i came out a little heated
about is that there's a picture on cnn
it was a cnn photo and they ran an
article saying
comparing police reaction and look this
is the first 12 hours
you're gonna make you don't know you
just don't know yet
and you're already putting this stuff
out there that's gonna make its way all
the way to the president-elect of the
united states
and you don't know do you know why
because you weren't there you're
somebody that's
that's quarantined writing and
interpreting the twitter feeds where do
your twitter feeds come from
do you follow activists you probably do
and you're probably getting the viral
clips that are cherry-picked that come
out and they say look
you know look this guy was taking a
selfie and you say oh these guys just
walked in
and you're making those claims before
the new york the new york times took
their
took a day and then they they put it out
and they gave an accurate
you know you know who the sources are
that are doing real journalism you know
who those are who are jumping on a wave
to get you outraged because they know
that that makes money
that that that that facilitates
from viewers but the the photo that went
viral that i even my mom said
was this photo outside the lincoln
memorial and you see
all of the the national guard in riot
gear
and in in the the idea is this was the
response to black lives matter
and you know these people just walked in
what date was that photo from it was
from june the second
does anybody remember that on may 29th
the president of the united states was
bunkering himself at the white house
that's the 29th 30th 31st first that's
the fifth
day you're trying to tell me you're the
the what you're selling me from this
image on the fifth day of a national
riot
the fifth day in washington even longer
if you can include
um washington dc to be specific
even longer if you include uh the
national crisis
that we're in you're going to tell me
you're going to take that and you're
going to take this guy getting a selfie
at some point
within the five-hour siege that broke
through the capital
and yes you did have people as i said
saying traitor and oath breaker
and others that were saying thank you
for your service and you're gonna cherry
pick those two
and you're gonna make this grand claim
without
talking and you can do it that's fine if
you're an activist
but you're gonna do it without talking
to the people that were on the ground
any of them doing any journalistic
taking any steps to be a journalist and
talk to people that were there and
find out what were the attitudes who is
there
how many how many times did they have to
breach the police
what was the structure why were they
going climb monkey bars up
up scaffolding there's there's a huge
this is a huge cataclysmic event
and people by the time i got to my car
friends
i went to social media and they were
they were sharing those exact points
they were saying
and it was lined up it was just and
you have to i trace it to the 2pm hour
and this is a very specific tweet that i
saw
from a reporter who actually inspired me
to come up to portland
over the summer robert evans he has been
embedded
with the leftists and and he markets
himself
as a watchdog for far-right extremism he
is
he is business insider uh had an art
article of his immediately critical of
of police and this is why
this all happened but he tweets at 2 15
uh something that would be proven wrong
and i just want to read this because
because if you have and i don't want to
single
out mr evans uh he's somebody who i
invited full disclosure onto my podcast
because i
i pitched to him we should talk about
the difference
of in-bed reporting domestically and
he's also been
abroad i want to say to like syria and
other places
when you're embedded abroad and
domestically what issues does this bring
up
and i wanted to have a real conversation
with him and
so i did approach him uh previously but
he tweets
at 2 15 blm supporters would have been
shot with live ammo the instant they
broke through the barricades
that's 2 15 p.m we're an hour and
uh you know a half roughly into this
thing
news isn't out yet that somebody was
shot and killed in the neck
so already the activist outrage is
churning
before the story is even a quarter on
its way
in real time the activist the keyboard
warriors
get this out there now now that's
an account with 187 000 followers
many of them young and that makes its
way
and i'm not saying it's just one person
i'm saying there could be parallel
thinkers that are
seizing upon the same talking point
pretty soon you have cnn
you know van jones is is echoing this
and saying young people feel this way
that if it were black people it would be
this response so we're making
no effort culturally to find out what
happened
who was there what they wanted they're
just
again it's heresy if you if you do
anything beyond
issuing the brand a fascist that's
it that's all that the that this
web journalistic culture
is willing to accept and i don't even i
use the word journalistic
in that term excuse me because because
how is this happening
and in full disclosure i gave him a
terse reply i said one you know a woman
was just shot and we
we got into it uh a little because i i
am critical of this tribalism and uh i
pointed out
something that would be later confirmed
by
the extremist uh that
uh the guy his name was mark this is the
thing these people give their names
they're not hiding behind masks
they're saying we're here for the
revolution and my name is mark is and
this is
the federalist who uh self-described
federalist who has neo-nazi
uh a spouse's neo-nazi beliefs that's uh
you know uh that's the best that i could
uh describe him
uh he uh he self-destruct
self-described extremist and there i'm
sure there were others like them
him that were pro coup now uh
so so anyways uh they were there
you know i'm not disputing that that you
had those people there
but that the dialogue became
about race so quickly by keyboard
activism
and it makes its way to younger people
that are working for
these big media companies that know
social just like when i worked for that
that company that had all the seed money
they were trying to get young people to
figure out
what what can be shared and it's this
tribal outrage stuff
so i saw this uh develop in real time
on twitter the first place i saw this
this connection made was ibrahmex kendi
tweeted that uh
i i hesitate to say exactly what he
tweeted because i won't get it perfectly
and
obviously there's a hazard in that but
the point was
effectively we all know what would have
happened if this had been
black people and my immediate thought
was
in 2021 i actually have no idea how it
would compare
right i i have seen so many instances
where the simple fact that uh you know
black lives matter is being used as a
banner
uh provides an amazing level of
protection
from any police enforcement of the most
obvious and important
laws so um anyway my sense was
that this was the creation of a false
fact right the fact that we have been
uh induced to accept is that the
uh the breach of the capital looked very
different because the people who were
engaged in it were overwhelmingly
white and the fact is even if that were
true we don't know it to be true
in 2021 there's every reason to suspect
it's not true because we have seen
a very different uh set of reactions
having everything to do with race and a
sensitivity
to race that has allowed for all kinds
of
lawlessness and violence and destruction
so
you know who knows but your point about
um if if you're a verificationist
right if you're not an honest broker and
you want to sell that story
and you can look through months and
months and months of
riots and find places where the police
reacted
arguably aggressively although to be
honest it wasn't
many of those but over the course of
many months you will have those
instances and you want to compare it
to this you know did you say five hour
siege of the capital right a you can't
compare the two because one is happening
in the aftermath of the other
and so therefore whatever happened in
the earlier phase has some in
uh has some impact potentially but if
you were going to try to do an honest
comparison
you would compare the first 12 hours
right
and you know even then you couldn't do
it because
that which is being attacked is
different an attack on the capital is
different than
an attack on the federal building in
portland
um so in any case the idea that
you don't it's not that they're failing
to do journalism they're trying to avoid
doing journalism
right what they want to do is they want
to advance a story that explains why
they are going to react in the way they
are to this
right they need a story that's clean and
so if they have to manufacture it from
whole cloth
by saying oh there's an alternative
universe in which the opposite happened
and there was a massacre why was there a
massacre
because the people who were storming the
capital weren't white
right well you just made that up right
that didn't happen what's more
you know as you point out you do have uh
the police shooting a white person
inside
the capitol uh which suggests that
you know whatever the story is it's
complex and it's
not a slam dunk that this was uh a
uh timid response i think there is a
legitimate question
as to why the capitol police
were not better prepared and why
there was not backup given the
possibility that something like this
would happen where was the national
guard
right i do think you know in light of
where we are and
all of the energy and heat surrounding
the election
and the counting of votes and the
certifying of
the election results that uh
it would have been wise to you know
spend what would presumably be a
relatively small number of million
dollars to prevent this from occurring
by having
uh the capacity to resist
anything that could be brought to bear i
do wonder why that didn't happen
but nonetheless the idea that there's
some clear story and that we all know
enough about the way things
function to know that if the skin color
of people who had
breached the capital had been different
that the outcome would have been
the inverse whatever that means that's
just nonsense and
it did develop online as you watched
people
who had a decidedly partisan perspective
attempt to figure
figure out how to formulate what was
happening in real time so that it fit
their world view there was no challenge
to their world view
it just simply matched everything they'd
been telling us all along and something
like this
the stories the most profound stories i
said this about covid
the most profound stories in our life
don't affirm what we already know they
challenge it
they challenge what we think and what
what our perceptions of the world are if
we
really take a deep dive and don't cling
to what
our uh ideology is and i
this whole year has been that for me you
know and
uh starting from you know
oh yeah and even before may because of
covet you have
it's just been a cataclysmic year and i
i i am
worried if folks are too entrenched i
i think the question that you bring up
is is why were they so
unprepared we're going to learn a lot
more i'm sure about that
in the people who are much more insiders
are going to be coming out with
information that
that is going to be very interesting in
regards to that but from my
point of view why i was flat-footed was
i
i left my my gas mask in the car i said
that that's for tonight you know because
you're you're tracing a pattern where
the daytime protests whether it's been
in washington dc at the supreme court or
at freedom plaza where they had the maga
million mega march has convened both on
november the 14th
and on december the 12th the
clashes were happening at night
afterwards or at least when the sun was
going down was where when you had
the political gang war of jets and
you know sharks coming out and and
beating on each other
on each other's helmets and spraying
each other and so forth
that was consistently happening
happening at night
so there was this relaxed attitude even
on my part which is
which was i'll get there at 1 30. i'll
listen to a little of the president's
speech
first and uh and then i'll get there
because i got to save myself for tonight
because tonight's going to be the big
one so
it was a departure from the law of
the patterns that we had seen we hadn't
seen
a right wing protest at day with the
exception again
of the bellwether of um salem
you know we hadn't seen that in
washington dc those million maga marches
in front of the the uh supreme court
and at at freedom plaza you you wouldn't
even say mostly peaceful they were 100
percent peaceful
that that group so when when it was
expected that that group for a you know
not even a third time because they also
went to you know washington monuments in
the supreme court several times
as part of the pattern it was not
expected in my mind that we were going
to have
a siege of the capital of the united
states of america it defied
my imagination and expectation and i'm
someone who said
this whole time it's going to boomerang
back the tactics the animus
everything filling in the blanks with
what they don't understand
because there's been no criticism about
what's been going on because the fascist
narrative
you have to believe it or or you're
you're a heretic
we knew all that and i still couldn't
couldn't
really see um that it was going to be
that big at the capitol even as i was
walking up
and burrowing myself into the crowd so
well that's fascinating um i realize
as much as it's hard to see even into
the next few hours
in circumstances like this do you have
any broader sense
you've spent a lot of time on both sides
of this battle between fringes
do you have a sense of where we're
headed well my hope
my hope one uh again i i another contact
and a lot of these contacts
are from the right because uh quite
simply people on the left aren't out
there they're not
mixing it up in in doing this it not
goes for
antifa aligned group protests blm and
um and the the maga movement protests
it's been mostly coverage from the right
and when i talk to them you know one one
vlogger said you know i think these
people have jobs to go back to a lot of
them
is what he's is is what he said and he
said you know i i
and i got a message that even protests
during
the inauguration there was initially
supposed to be
and before this before the capital
it was already making its way around
that the inauguration
protests would be cancelled from the
right which was
interesting sort of sort of message of
this is it
you know that that morning that was
going around now i don't know if that's
the case there may still be inauguration
day protests in the nation's capital
from the right
i am not sure but that's the attitude
was you know from some people that you
know and it depends on the fringe
those people are still pro pro coup
so to speak that something else will
still happen
but even from someone who i saw burning
a black lives matter flag who i
said that's something i you know
in vehemently against burning other
people's symbols let alone
a hashtag motto and for that person it
meant something different but
you know there was a dialogue there
where i said that's not something i can
obviously get behind and i just want to
point out that everything you're
projecting
onto that slogan is all of this other
stuff
and then i asked the person you know
maybe the communist flag did you think
and the person was like oh no i have one
that i'm gonna burn
um you know so so that i engage with
with with people that are
on what we would call extreme emotional
cliffs
in regards to all of this is part of the
story and that's why i engage that's why
i talk to that person because you know
what was interesting
when i talked to that person the next
day after the siege of the capital
that person said to me
i feel i'm i feel awful this is the
person who said i'm so glad i wasn't
there myself
of course they have to protect the
capital can you imagine
you know if it wasn't us and it was
another group you know what would we be
saying there was this soul-searching
that was going on of
have we become the very thing
that we said we were against how did we
become that
and that's a question that in conflict
that
that should always be asked yes i think
every side should be asking this
and um frankly
you know i i hate to be somebody who's
always saying you know
things are worse than you think and
until we
wake up to that they're going to
continue in that direction
my feeling is we could be very close to
turning the corner but if what we keep
doing is doubling down
on uh you know on our priors and
basically buttressing whatever phony
narrative we're being
sold then the trajectory is pretty clear
right
we're headed to disaster well let me
tell you i mean
and we need that reflection it's just if
the press
will give it to us and this is where it
comes down to
a part of a system that i've been a part
of
that needs to be held accountable and
there should be some whistleblowing
there i would challenge anyone who's
been around this all year
who wanted to report something but was
told they couldn't
who had their stories rejected who
saw their their institution pursuing a
narrative
there is an obligation to tell the truth
of what was going on
and how narratives were built and let me
go
back to that cnn photo that was
juxtaposed
of again day five of of the washington
dc
riots and was juxtaposed to somebody
taking a selfie because that narrative
again makes its way from activists to
mainstream media to the president-elect
of the united states who came out in in
and echoed the very same um talking
point
that a pacific northwest activist
journalist
leftist journalist was was tweeting at 2
15 pm by the next day
president-elect is saying it and again
it's not just one person it was a lot of
people because these people are all
interlinked
and they yes they yes and each other and
they say yes
and yes and and all of the activists
uh you know there's a woman who who uh
blogs for or writes articles for teen
vogue
which i mentioned pri that has this big
anarchist section as well
of anarchist literature and uh you know
i follow all these these
people there's a there's there is a
social justice
anti-fascist group that
is extremely quick to spin the narrative
and these younger kids are hooked into
them
so they get these accounts have a
hundred thousand followers
these these younger folks start
um parroting it and so if you
tell me if you work for cnn and this is
your bio i'm not going to name the
person
but if this is your bio um
on social i'm part of cnn's
race and equality team this beat speaks
to who
this person is and sees the world um
telling telling stories of
multiculturalism
latinx black indigenous and asian
american communities now that's
something we're all for
and me at least and the intersection of
race with sports gaming
education and more now as i gave that
disclaimer in the middle of it to defend
myself
from the fact that i was naming all you
know
diverse races of which i'm a part a part
of i and of course i want equal
opportunity and better understanding in
this world
if that you know what was it called
again if that
team is the
uh race and equality team which i'm for
sounds great
right and this speaks to your background
in your your experience
if that lens is
first and foremost on the internet with
the young
team of millennial and uh
generation z uh
writers and bloggers if that
is the always going to be the lens i'm
concerned and i would give this
challenge to any young people that are
listening
uh to to me right now because i was in
portland and i did see moments where the
pacifists like myself were at the
bullhorn
and some folks who were in black block
were like willing to listen
and willing to hear other ideas and if
you're part of that group
and have discussions beyond what's
popular
in getting the likes and getting the
retweets on twitter
have discussions even off twitter for
you know let's let's help us do us all a
favor
and have these discussions about ideas
and
uh and ask yourself if everything really
needs to be
always through that lens and always
through the people who are telling you
to do that who you retweet and you look
to
if it always has to be that because that
may be that may be somebody's personal
obsession
that may be somebody's identity of
social justice keyboard warrior
and everything about them and not enough
about the people who are on the streets
and the stories that we need to learn
more about
in regards to people who do not think
and like us
and see the world the world like we do
that inhabit the same nation
that we do and that would be my
challenge
and my hope for for for young folks and
and everybody because
i get it from my friends my again you
know my best friend since i was uh
in high school uh hasn't talked to me
since september and won't and won't
assort with uh uh uh trump apologist
uh again not my yeah it's not what you
are
but if you if he sees you as that then
uh
he by his own rules can't talk to you
well one
one quote uh from another friend
said was what you're working against is
the human brain in some ways
that the way that
we are stubborn and we insist on seeing
things a perfect way and if somebody
challenged that i have another
friend who's who's bless him he's so
reliable that if i say anything about
equal like trying to this is
similar or or that make any comparisons
i get a just a rant of profanity
which uh the best way the best way to
deal with
with profane rants is humor it just has
to it has to be
it has to be we have to be able to laugh
again
we can't be so policed in every emotion
that we have
that we can't figure a way to laugh at
the absurdity of
what we have been through collectively
for the last you know
the last 11 months yeah i agree with you
i think in some sense
um you have to be able to
look at anyone with decency uh
and see their humanity and then
you know those with humanity and it
isn't everyone but it's most of us
have to embrace nuance which
frankly the one thing you can know about
nuance
is that it's going to deliver you some
things some things about nuance are
going to line up with what you expect
and some things about it are going to go
the other way and if your point is i'll
take the fraction of nuance
that goes my way you're not interested
in nuance so
we're all going to have to do that and
somehow
resist what comes back at us for
engaging in that kind of heresy
i'm going to ask five people
that i emailed before i got to the
capitol
actually the day before i said this is
what i had interviewed
the chairman of the proud boys which
again a huge heresy
back in september and then tried to get
comments
and this is on unblocked podcast which
is part of publicreport.org
i talked to him i got his views and he
told me he sees
his only extreme views view is that
there should be no gun laws
which is interesting that he got himself
arrested with two
cartridges uh there are some that
are speaking of as if that might be
deliberate to challenge gun laws and so
forth but you know
i don't want to get too far into that he
is somebody who i interviewed because
the proud boys have been this
this on the receiving end of a campaign
that you will never be more than white
supremacists not just that
not just that you are that you will
never be more than that there's no
possibility for you to evolve
out of that we've decided that's what
you are because we've
picked these instances but
but we have to ask ourselves how and
this is something i encourage i'm not
going to
volunteer any opinions on the proud boys
i'm going to ask everybody
to start doing their own research and
figure out
how extreme when you listen to
interviews
um if the people who are who are
are these people platform
ethnonationalists
i can answer that that's no they're
platforming something else and other
other conservative ideals that uh they
say match up with this populist maga
movement that's why you see them as
security detail in sacramento like i do
um when i have gone to sacramento and so
forth but
but you know again this the heresy of
saying to people
don't take my word for it at least look
into it yourself
because the press has decided on cert
that certain people
are beyond redemption and they won't
talk about it so if you're a publication
that's decided that a particular group
of people are beyond redemption
and for some publications and editors in
chief it might be 70 million plus people
i challenge you i challenge those five
people that i sent emails to
who were members of the raw story which
is the big left
one of the big left tabloids uh the
huffington post
um the daily beast if you're one of
those
people that work at these institutions
that that decidedly
pursue one narrative i challenge you to
do
other research and buck your own
viewership because we're not going to
get anywhere unless you do
if you keep making money and exploiting
our divisions with this kind of
sensational content
that is in yes you click up the
engagement
you get the likes and and you profit off
that but the price that we are paying as
a society
should trouble you when you try to
uh decompress at the end of the day
from everything that we are taking in
from this
heightened portrayal of anybody who
belongs to the opposite political side
of the spectrum yeah i
i agree and i i i like your phraseology
that they are exploiting our decisions
for uh financial gain and it's not
only you know it's the risk that they're
putting us to that's the most
troubling because if they keep
exploiting it there will be no putting
this nation back together
and the frightening prospect of it's
coming apart what that will do to the
west
um who that will leave the world
open to is uh you know the cost is
incalculable
so yes they have a moral obligation to
stop doing that
i would say and it's not inconsistent
with anything you said but there are
irredeemable people
they're not common and that's the
problem is when you take
you know large numbers many millions of
people and you decide
they're irredeemable you're almost
certainly making
a serious error so you know are there
people in the proud boys who are
white nationalists i have very little
doubt that that's true
but yeah absolutely i don't think it
characterizes them all
and um in any case it is the obligation
of journalists
to to figure out what's true not to
impose what's true
on the story which is what most
journalists are currently doing
my interview with um enrique tario
and i do challenge him on um you know
this is the dialogue that we need to be
having which is why
are is there a proud boys channel that
uh has racist content
and and are you denouncing that he says
he is he says
that they do denounce that and he wants
to see more denunciation
from from the left of our extreme
elements so this was a
very real conversation that we had and
one thing that he said
was i think the lesson is people need to
be heard
that's what they want that that he's
platforming
not ethnonationalism he's platforming
that people want to be heard
that should be a message to all of us
and i know it came from somebody q
you've our most of this country is
determined as a as a
uh irredeemable individual i would again
challenge you and say do your research
already mr tario was
when i got out of the capital i stopped
by a salvadorian restaurant and i hadn't
eaten
and univision the station that i am a
freelancer for
maybe still i don't know because i
haven't worked for them since i got
furloughed
jorge ramos was debating enrique tario
on national univision news and they were
talking about these issues
and i saw that nice and my jaw dropped
because i i did not expect a mainstream
outlet to do it
and they were speaking in spanish and
sometimes switching to english
and i was watching jorge ramos who we
know
is is very left and anti um
maga and has had his run-ins uh with the
president united states himself
and they're having this debate and i
looked at that and i said yes that's
good i'm proud that i work for that
that organization that they're willing
to take the risk
and have that conversation in you know
somewhat of a cultural bubble
of of spanish speakers uh but those are
the kind
we need to take the that lead and have
those kind of hard
tough conversations that don't go smooth
and there's a budding of heads and and
you you know your viewers will get mad
at you
let your viewers get mad at you let your
viewers be outraged that you talked to
that person
that you platformed them what's the
worst that's going to happen
yep well you know the fact is there's a
large
number of uh that's not a large number
in absolute terms but a significant
quadrant of the podcast landscape
demonstrates that actually although yes
lots of people
won't be interested in hearing things
that violate their core beliefs
there's a lot of other people who are
nothing but interested in hearing
about perspectives that don't match
their priors and so
it's amazing that there's not a a
mainstream journalistic outlet
interested in
tapping into that i think it's going
gonna have to be a story for another day
but
um the question of why that that
journalistic outlet doesn't
doesn't rise and take advantage of the
obvious hunger
that many of us have for decent
journalism that's a real question
i just i hope that people can start
talking to each other again
because i don't remember when i don't i
didn't know it's like i i didn't know
that it got
this bad and i'm standing at the capitol
and it's being
ransacked and um
and i've stood other places that were
ransacked and again
i don't make a differentiation of of
to me a riot or an insurrect to some
anarchists an insurrection is an
insurrection
that's why they're the wild card here
and you'll get people on the right that
look back at the capital and say
antifa was there well i don't think you
understand
what you mean by that because antifa
groups are
in that social justice leftist category
but there are anarchists that cross over
because as as one anarchist famously
said to me on facebook
before deleting everything and blocking
me
we don't care who's [ __ ] [ __ ] up as
long as they're [ __ ] [ __ ] up
yup that does sound uh sound like a
familiar sentiment
i think it's in all our interest to
confront
extremism on our own sides
and i've never seen this story just as a
right left story
i've seen it as a as us as a nation uh
uh
addressing our bigger problems and
polarization that that drives us
to to these emotional passions where we
can't even
uh see to uh to to respect talk
or let anybody be heard yeah i agree the
fridges cannot be allowed to drive
frankly um the patriots in all camps
have to come together and begin to piece
uh our national story um
together newly because
we are in jeopardy we do not agree on
even the facts
but we can agree that this nation
has immense potential that it has never
been perfect
that it has outperformed expectations in
many regards and been a model for
freedom
across the world and that the chances
that starting with a fresh sheet of
paper are going to result in a vastly
better place are
vanishingly low so let's get to the job
of
fixing it and those points of agreement
that
the black lives matter woman from utah
her name is jakari kelly and thad
is the proud boys leader that became
friends and they realized that they
both stood against white supremacy they
could say that
so they said they stood against white
supremacy they were against
the school-to-prison pipeline and that
they were for prison reform they were
both for
police reform they're both for getting
uh
big money out of elections and so
there's that was
half of the points of commonality when
you
move on to like housing and
mental health and other other issues
that we
all have a common interest in addressing
and if those two
can figure out to have a conversation
and come to agreement
then by god we all should we all should
be able to challenge ourselves
and what our friends are going to think
and how people are going to point the
finger at us
and call us heretics because we talk to
the other side
if they can do it they even said as much
on new year's eve on unblocked podcasts
when they were talking to me they were
they said if we can do this you know
other people can right and i think this
has been the experience of any
who have uh ventured into
the no man's land in the middle is that
we discover
actually that there is a tremendous
reason
for us to come together and that in some
sense
i think one of the suspicions that many
people who have
made the journey happen onto is
that somebody wants us divided
that's why we're this way right it's not
that we're naturally divided
right nobody nobody reasonable wants one
race to triumph over others right
people want a good world and the
divisions are largely artificial
and you have to ask yourself well is it
is it because
a lot of people come out with conspiracy
i always
my answer to that has always been is
that conspiracy or is it incompetence
and it's my experience there's been a
vast amount of incompetence
well and there's incompetence there's
natural emergent processes and there's
conspiracy there will always be some
admixture between these things
hmm yeah i
i just i that the part of the story that
has me shaking my head as the press
because that's that's who i've been
representative of
and that they couldn't see that that
this would boomerang back that they
couldn't see if we don't
cover this violence if we don't talk
about it honestly what our side is doing
in a polarized tribalized world
of course all of these techniques
everything that we've been doing
is going to to be redirected and say
well you think you're the only one who
can do that
this is and the one thing that i the one
refrain in the capital
was this is our house this is my house
this is our house
that this belongs to the people that's
the statement that they were that were
making
and when i came down and i had i was
composing this in my mind
this this you know tweeter or a post to
my friends saying hey
you know one thing that nobody discussed
up there ever you know what was not
mentioned at all
race that's what was in my head and then
i turn it i get into reception and
everything is race
yeah everything on this you could just
doom scroll
of a race post about race and i and i
said no that's not the takeaway from
what i saw
and there are there is some cherry
picking that's pretty hilarious when van
jones
is talking about how young people are
saying this and
and and on cnn and he's talking about
well if it was
if it were black people that were in the
capital they're playing
b-roll from in the capital and right
next to him is a person of color
in the in the b-roll which which was
just
very uh kind of amusing that
that because you know i've worked in in
media
in the b-roll timing the b-roll with
what a guest is going to say is
impossible right
you're you're playing this this footage
uh
from the control room and he doesn't see
it so he doesn't see that there's
a person of color right next to him in
the capitol where he's talking about if
this were
black people coming into the capitol and
then you know who was also there was
that
uh young guy um i think his name is
philip
he organized uh he's black and he's the
one who got the two
his two front teeth punched out by
berkeley antifa when they mobilized
against him in
san francisco on october the 17th and
i saw that i was there and he gave this
he gave a speech anyway and they were
throwing you know
bottles at him and uh there was only a
dozen of them
and then the crowd that was that day the
crowd went all the way around the block
and then beat the [ __ ] out of uh
a guy just because he had a trump flag
and it was a mob
black block mob customized shields that
was the day that
that i talked about elders in the
background that the young kids were
coming and
coming back to and so forth um philip
was at the cap
i interviewed him as well oh this is one
thing if it can be
edited in i'll make up a page
publicreport.org
slash capital with a no capital
and publicreport.org capital
all put in interviews that
at the capitol including that
not you know proclaimed extremist that
it showed yes this person is there i'm
not sugar coating this uh
also there was the the grandmothers for
trump who said they were in the capitol
in that first breach
also i talked to villain when he came
out
after he witnessed the death of one of
the women i also have
um uh philip who
is this um very well known and those
gripers hang around
him because they don't that's
interesting because
because they've been portrayed as racist
and anti-semitic
and then they hang around philip a lot
too
in fact on black lives matter plaza on
january the 5th
he he took his shirt off and he was
there and they were saying
they were chanting [ __ ] blm him and them
so
it's it's all these weird sort of
surreal alliances and
cultural you know subcultural currents
that um are going on with certain
um with these alt-right young young
people who are coming up as well
and uh uh it's it's it's
been hard for people to parse because
it's just you have to take a deep dive
into it and
at some point i appreciate you reigning
me in because i just have
so much that i've uh learned and
experienced that i can just keep going
you know
yeah well i think um there is
an unending series of things and you
know one of the things i detect in
talking to you
is that you don't necessarily realize
how remote this story is to most people
right they're parsing just the thinnest
sliver
of uh what's on the surface
you know in part because that's what
they're being fed and
uh anyway there's just the simple fact
of the story is more complex than you
think
is i think a key part of the message and
i hope people will uh
take it very seriously i hope so too you
know
i've been living that charlie day meme
where charlie day's at the cork board
and he's going like this and it has all
the strings
attached and i think someone even made
fun of me with it
but uh uh it's
the failure of our institution our
journalistic institution
that has me very worried my my view on
guns has changed
because i used to argue against you know
guns and banning assault rifles and i
used to argue
very uh though i do think there should
be some control especially for people
under the age of 25 and
from what i've seen in other words uh
out there but that's just my my personal
thing but what i'm saying is that
this this story challenged me because i
saw
a vacuum if your media institutions fail
then your leaders don't know what's
going on well you could say the same
thing about
uh universities uh you know basically
all of the institutions are failing and
you're seeing
journalism because that's your home but
it's across the board right there's
really not
a major institution that you can point
to and say that one's healthy
and because of that yes our leaders are
flying blind they're there's no one to
tell them that their arrogance is going
to
you know crash the the airplane into the
mountain
uh and so anyway that's why
that's why some of us are trying to
raise the alarm is that the danger
of taking all of the things that allow
civilization to function and screwing
them all up at once
couldn't possibly be greater right we're
we're
uh we're flying blind and there's
nothing more dangerous than that
well hopefully i can get some people to
open their eyes and just watch
a little bit about who these people were
at the capitol um
and again i i've said i've i condemn
all of this i didn't i didn't i'm i'm a
pacifist i don't
i don't believe in ideologies even i'm
trying to get
the story and so on publicreport.org
slash capital with an o capital i will
put
video of people that i talk to
in the in the capital and i'll just have
that laid out on one page so people can
listen to some of these characters
including the bearded john fogerty fan
uh who who led me into the fray so to
speak and i said i would doc
and he kept saying where's my press
where's my press
and uh so he had an idea of what i was
there for
that uh but um the point i will make you
know some people
it was hairy i mean it was it was
intense and i didn't feel the crowd
would turn on me
that's a feeling that i get when i go
into blm plaza
when i was kicked out of blm plaza in
our second conversation i tell a story
about how i was worried that the crowd
would turn on me and i even
kind of there's a guy that was on the
megaphone
who uh i'd seen him sick people
on to other people before so to kind of
defuse it i kind of was just very
even flirtatious with him of just being
no relaxed i'm on your team kind of
thing
because i knew if he saw me as a trump
supporter and he started yelling in the
megaphone
i would be mobbed by the black bloc and
and i even told him i said i'm an
independent journalist and they said no
you're not
why if you're an independent journalist
why are you uh
you look like you just got out of a job
from a construction site is what they
said and i was like
and i started talking about anarchism
and they didn't they're like see that's
the mistake
you you thought we were anarchists and
it's just like oh my gosh i can't get it
anywhere with these people and then
and they're like what do you think about
juneteenth and it's like i don't have
plans what what
did i what do you mean and i couldn't
remember which one that was and i was
like
you know i'm usually really good at
dates and then i
and i said something about tulsa and i
was wrong because of course it's the
uh final emancipation from from texas
but
the president had scheduled originally
the june 20th rally on juneteenth and so
i got
confused with the tulsa massacre and all
of a sudden they were like nope
you're fash you're fast that's what we
think you're fash
and so i was escorted out and it wasn't
even good enough for me to be a block
away they had to take me
um even further a block and a half one
full city block and a half away from
black lives matter plaza
so do i get nervous at the capitol crowd
yeah i got nervous in the capital crowd
but i knew that the fanaticism
was um
i didn't think it would turn on me now
villain said he saw
one person with a camera who was
confronted so
it's not impossible yeah but the but the
mo
of the leftist operation security
is to control the messaging control the
press
control the messaging control the public
really
yeah well it goes back to what we were
talking about earlier where the need
to curate what the public sees
in order to justify what they're up to
is so intense that yeah they can't
afford to have somebody
walking around asking questions filming
what they want
because it will upend their narrative
yeah and
let me read you one thing because i uh
now that we're just kind of fast and
loose
so i i responded to robert evans
original you know
because i said i also pointed out i said
uh every they used every anarcho tool
you all developed these last seven
months only they had the numbers and
leadership to
go big so they did uh
look that's a provocative statement
again i was i even
apologize on twitter i said look i'm
sorry i was terse because i just come
down from the capitol and i couldn't
believe everybody was talking about race
and you're tweeting this at 2 15 before
you've realized that a woman's been shot
and killed and you're creating a false
narrative that people waltzed in
when i've just been in the thick of it
and you're being a keyboard warrior
so that was my point of view when i said
that later i apologize for the terseness
i said look we should we should debate
about this about
embed reporting and what i'm trying to
do
how that doesn't fit in and so forth and
he said you're not worth debating
you're a liar part of why we got where
we
are right now is by dating and
debating and platforming idiots like you
and acting like you aren't lying
grifters
for my part i'm muting you your time in
the spotlight ended long ago
yeah those are a lot of tried and true
lines and approaches strung together as
if they mean something
yeah then he tweets later not to me
the funny thing is the funny thing about
this is i'm
not capitalized a particularly skilled
investigative reporter
i do very little of the cool [ __ ] my
colleagues at bellingcat do to unravel
russian assassin
assassination rings all i do is open
browsers type in urls
and read pretty much reflects
what you were saying yeah i i i'm like
is he being ironic
i i can't tell so this guy again
not only that he published to his
followers an
email that i sent him to his crew
and didn't tag me in it so i would only
find it again if i went on another
browser and looked for my name
and the all it is how incriminating is
this
the email from me from jeremy elquin
on december the 29th 2020 hi robert
i wanted to see if you would be up for a
podcast conversation on either your
platform or mine
best jeremy lee quinn and then he
characterizes it
jeremy quinn showing his true cards as a
fascist sympathizer
here is a screen grab of an email where
he tried to get me on his podcast
this idiot was one of the sources for a
new york times article
about dangerous anarchists who quote
checks notes broke some windows
so the tribal signaling even
of the ironic left
of look we know what we're doing but you
know what
you don't get to talk about it yep we
talk about it
that's exactly what he's doing and
what's his evidence an
email of me asking him to have a
conversation on a podcast well i
i'm a list you know i've seen some
incriminating emails in my day but that
one takes the cake
and then i got a kid right responding to
it
alt that's all he says it's just alt and
then i say oh excuse me
um i was just trying to you know you
play it innocent is
and and naive not
because you're lying to them but because
you are naive enough to engage with them
on good faith
and you said look i'm just asking to
have a conversation now there were some
issues and
if there were terse words i'm just
trying to get to common ground and so
forth and have this talk
and then i got this ironic you have
reached a automatic ai
system like they're writing just these
snarky
this is this will generate a please
leave your concern and this will
generate a response and it's just like
oh
you guys are just you're i can't i just
i can't i can't yeah please you know
just please
stop just stop with it stop with the
twitter culture
because the twitter culture is it seems
harmless
but you're actually controlling this
this
block and follow culture is just ruining
us
just taking us down yeah it's making it
impossible for us to
navigate and find the humanity in each
other on the other hand i think
your responsibility is clear you did say
in that email
your channel or mine which is a classic
white nationalist dog whistle
yes your your channel or mine
yeah yeah you outed yourself but i mean
other than that you've played it pretty
well
yeah oh man it was again i told you this
on the first podcast
you know to wake up one morning and just
see your name
just being you're called a white
nationalist
somebody is tweeting at jack dorsey jack
you you know jack jack this guy is you
know he's infiltrated the new york times
and this is you know this is can you and
it's just like
what are people doing you know
what what what what are we doing here
there's a
there was a conversation look the
article from the new york times by
pharah stockman who's a
pulitzer a woman of color and a pulitzer
prize-winning
journalist was was asking questions of
whether these anarchist
tactics insurrectionists um
and i if the if there was one criticism
or differentiation rather from the new
york times article in my work is i
emphasize the tactics i always say look
these are shareable virally enhanced you
know
tactics and maybe that wasn't emphasized
enough and they seized on it and said
see the new york times is blaming the
anarchists on everything
look you know and it's like and then the
socialist
rag came out and said conspiracy
theorist jeremy quinn
uh is echoing the talking points
of of attorney general barr and the
president
as if that's my motivating you know and
you just you can't
have like an intelligent conversation
right no you can't
it's designed to prevent intelligent
conversation um
so anyway i i i
greatly appreciate the attempt to
bootstrap intelligent conversation in
the midst of
insanity which is obviously yeah what
has taken over
all right um this has been fascinating
uh
i will say for my viewers
there is a jeremy lee quinn
dark horse episode up for you to look at
there is another one that we recorded
that has not been fully processed yet i
think i'm going to put this one up next
because it's so
timely and then the part b of our
initial interview will go up
probably next week where can people find
you
publicreport.org publicreport.org is me
documenting uh i call subtitle it under
the cover of protests everything that i
witnessed
and was able to aggregate through video
from minneapolis which i
i did not go to minneapolis until much
later i
uh so a lot of the initial minneapolis
footage is of course
uh aggregated footage but as being
non-monetized and i i have not made a
penny
i've lost i've spent a lot on a credit
card but as being non-monetized i
i considered this project
publicreport.org
as a uh i was able as a fair use
project for the public good the public a
public service therefore i
am taking from other people so you will
recognize other people's footage
a lot of my own footage which i have
shot either in black block
dressed up myself in different cities
like portland rochester new york
and in different cities in california or
not in black block at all when i was in
louisville
and walking around in a flak jacket
myself
or when i was in um trump territory when
i was in tulsa
at that rally on uh it was the
june the 20th and i was tailing the
proud boys
at that point you know with an american
flag handkerchief to blend in and so
forth
um so i've i've i've done it all and at
publicreport.org it's
there's a lot of material there that you
know you could take a look at bit by bit
i also interviewed anarchists old school
anarchists who were uh
during all this who talked to me uh twin
cities
workers defense alliance put out it you
know saying don't talk to
to jeremy lee quinn because uh
information
security um operation security that that
i was against
i was get against the interest of
operation security
but i just i have to tell this one story
when i did go to minneapolis
i went to the occupied zone there is
still an occupied zone in minneapolis of
george floyd square
which is a mixed residential and
business area where george floyd was
killed
and it's a two block radius or so area
with checkpoints on all four sides
uh checkpoint um little you know
makeshift shelters
and you'll see that it's it's a [ __ ] off
cop zone
so to speak you have spray painted
barricades and so forth
um i went in you know a couple times and
this one time i
walked up i was in all black long black
you know
how i dress sometimes and scarf and so
forth and the car picks
pulls up and the guy who's
says i haven't met you yet how you doing
and i and i
and i introduced myself and he said he
introduced himself and he said so how
you're at this barricade now
and i said uh i kind of for a split
second i was like
what if i said i am um what would happen
and and i said no no i'm just passing
through i'm in from out of town and
i i dropped a couple names of people i
knew or whatever and that were local and
uh but but but it was funny
that and it was similar to the first
time i was in black block in california
somebody just recruited me and asked me
to watch that alley to see if the cops
were gonna
we're gonna bum rush us you know and
bull rushes or rather
um and uh that autonomous feeling
of we don't know who's doing what yeah
and
that was copied that's what i saw at the
capitol and that's what i keep
trying to get people to understand
leftist autonomous
organizing everything down to
your you know public face site of wild
protest
because it's all this coded language of
this is what we're doing and
that's how those flyers work from the
pacific northwest youth liberation front
we're doing this and then we there's a
dress and black do this
you know there's all these codes the
operational
horizontally or organized decentralized
except you know there's always some sort
of leadership and and my
theory is that what went down at the
capitol is because they had the biggest
leadership
the the the the the
the president united states they had a a
they had
somebody that was leading them in spirit
to to do that yeah and that and the
president of the united states should be
held accountable for that
well it has to be held accountable for
laws he actually
violated um you know but that's that's a
high bar
um so anyway conversation for another
time what's your twitter handle
sorry oh yeah i need people on twitter
because i have
i get attacked constantly and i have no
count
sort of uh people rather i don't want to
use a a
a banned word i i i was going to say
calvary
some people have problems with that word
i i hear it's problematic
but what i mean is i don't have yeah
on my side i get attacked and that
attack gets
890 likes you know and i say something
and i'm lucky if i get one so if you
want to join the fray
i'm at j lee quinn
which is at j l e e q
u i n n and you can also google
unblocked
podcast and uh findpublicreport.org and
there's
different links to that as well great
well thanks so much for joining us
really appreciate the update and uh keep
us posted
thank you for having me all right be
well everyone
[Music]
you